la ciudad de Nápoles está viviendo una
verdadera explosión de júbilo decenas de
miles de personas han salido a las
calles de la ciudad a celebrar el
scudetto la victoria del Campeonato
italiano de serie a de fútbol con el
resultado del partido de este jueves el
empate uno a uno frente al equipo de
udine El Napoli acumula una tal ventaja
de puntos que ya matemáticamente no
puede ser sobrepasado por Ninguno de los
otros equipos presentes en la
competencia en la ciudad el fervor y la
Euforia se han apoderado de los hinchas
del equipo que festejan una victoria
histórica hace 33 años que el Napoli no
ganaba el scudetto las únicas dos veces
que lo ganó fue en la época en la cual
el argentino Diego Armando Maradona fue
capitán del equipo gracias a esta
Victoria el Napoli lleva de vuelta al
sur de Italia un tipo título de
campeonato monopolizado durante 22 años
por equipos del Norte del país la fiesta
seguramente continuará hasta el alba
pero para poder levantar el codiciado
trofeo los napolitanos deberán esperar
hasta el final oficial de la temporada
El próximo 4 de junio